and immediately a vision of Margaret
Hamilton arose up in front of me saying
I'll get you and your little dog and I
thought Jesus Mary and Joseph I've I've
just had a vision and it isn't the
Virgin Mary coming down out of the
clouds it's Margaret Hamilton and she
has something to say to me and I better
pick up my pen and write it down author
Gregory Maguire fell in love with the
Wizard of Oz when he was young one
question stuck with him are people born
Wicked
or do they have wickedness thrust upon
them what is the nature of evil what
really do I mean when I say somebody is
bad somebody is wicked was I talking
about the presence of Satan so obviously
lots of people would say that Judy
Garland is a gay icon um I wondered if
you agree why you think that is oh 100%
100% a lot of the conversation starts
with uh with the Wizard of Oz Oz is a
very queer place and has always been
even from the L frank books it's always
been queer yeah I think so for sure Gay
the world of Oz itself is just
especially in this film is just very
inclusive as a whole I mean so many
queer actors are in it as well which is
beautiful well you've been open about
identifying as queer so were you able to
embrace that as a teenager was that easy
no because I don't think I had the
language at 11 I remember saying to my
friends I was like does anyone else
think they're gay there's a lot of
people who love Wicked there's a lot of
people who need Wicked kid and I'm
especially the most beautiful community
in the entire world it's very much a
story about Discovery there's sort of
this innate understanding of what it
feels like to be someone who's different
uh I'm a gay man in a world that has
come around quite a bit in the course of
my lifetime as a fan as a person who has
loved this for 20 years I know that this
fights for truth and the complexities of
being misunderstood and it's all about
identity I think and finding yourself
and aligning what your belief system is
with your actions it is my heart's
desire to become a sorceress thank you
and to have this film at this moment
urgently at this moment means the world
listen to me you're not being told the
whole story this is also called
education that's how I was inspired to
write Wicked